Hey guys Trace here for another DNews short!
Teeth are super important for us.
They allow us to chew our food and break it
down for digestion.
So why aren’t we aren’t born with the
teeth we have as adults.
What is the purpose of having baby teeth first?
Most mammals, including humans, are diphyodonts,
meaning we grow two sets of teeth in our lifetime.
This is because baby mouths can’t fit a
full set of 32 adult teeth.
Instead, we start with a set of 20 baby teeth,
also called deciduous teeth.
You're actually born with these teeth already
developed inside your jaw!
In rare cases, babies can even be born with
teeth already in their mouth, called natal
teeth.
For most people though, they start poking
through the gums at around 6 months to 2 years
old.
Children need these deciduous teeth so that
they can chew food, advance their speech and
develop muscles in their mouths.
But, perhaps most importantly, baby teeth
forge a space in our gums for adult teeth
to grow in later.
They’re like little space holders, patiently
waiting while bigger teeth grow underneath.
As we develop, our mouths grow bigger and
eventually become too big for our 20 baby
teeth.
If we kept our initial set of teeth, they
would be tiny in our adult mouths, and have
huge spaces between them, making chewing close
to impossible.
So when they start to fall out around age
6, a set of ‘permanent’ teeth emerge!
A lot of animals don’t follow this two-set
system.
For instance, an alligator can replace its
teeth roughly 50 times in its lifetime.
But unfortunately humans, we don’t have
that luxury.
After childhood, we only get one set.
Which is why it’s SUPER important to take
care of them.
But what happens if you don’t?
What would happen if you just...stopped brushing.
You can find that out in this video here.
What about you?
Got any weird stories about losing your teeth?
Do you still have some baby teeth?
Let us know!
Don’t forget to subscribe and keep coming
back for more DNews every day.